llegó el tiempo de hablar de economía en
france 24 estábamos con jorge hurtado
nuestro periodista jorge bienvenido y
llevan seis meses desde que el salvador
adoptó al mundo adoptó el bitcoin como
moneda que ha pasado desde entonces así
que bueno según el presidente nadie
bukele desde ese momento hasta ahora al
menos cuatro millones de salvadoreños
han adoptado el bitcoin y el 65 por
ciento de la población ya está haciendo
uso de la billetera digital pero todas
las oportunidades de esta tecnología se
han visto opacada por una implementación
casi improvisada manejada con sigilo por
el gobierno y de alguna forma poco
transparente de su entrada en vigencia
que le prometió que el bitcoin serviría
para que miles de salvadoreños que no
tienen acceso a la banca privada
lograran ingresar así como generar
inversión extranjera y recibir remesas
sin intermediarios pero los números
revelan que el entusiasmo por la
tecnología ha venido en descenso
conversamos antes con ricardo castañeda
él es economista del instituto
centroamericano de estudios fiscales
sobre qué ha pasado en medio año de la
implementación del bitcoin en s
en términos generales
toda la adopción del bitcoin como moneda
de curso legal en el salvador ha sido un
experimento con una alta dosis de
improvisación y una alta dosis de
opacidad las estadísticas oficiales
en torno al uso al manejo de recursos
relacionados con el vito pues
prácticamente se han declarado como
reservadas sin embargo si uno toma en
cuenta por ejemplo los elementos que en
su momento llegó a plantear el
presidente bucl que alrededor de 3
millones de personas habían descargado
un archivo wallet estábamos hablando de
que casi la mitad de la población
entonces había descargado esta
aplicación sin embargo las encuestas más
recientes muestran que alrededor de 7 de
cada 10 personas nunca han hecho una
transacción en bitcoin y prácticamente
en el diario vivir la mayoría de las
transacciones no es en el país se siguen
haciendo en dólares
jorge pero si el bitcoin no ha sido la
promesa que se hizo porque el gobierno
insiste en crear un bitcoin siri o en
emitir bonos respaldados en bitcoins así
es bueno inclusive bukele ha dicho que
esta ciudad sería libre de impuestos se
usaría energía geotérmica de un volcán
cercano para la minería de las monedas
digitales y que sería financiado por
este famoso bono volcán el proyecto
muestra 'el salvador' alejándose de la
disciplina de los mercados tradicionales
de deuda soberana mientras otros lo ven
como una señal de que el script o
divisas están entrando rápidamente en el
financiamiento global lo cierto es que
el bitcoin genera una tensa relación
entre el gobierno salvadoreño y los
organismos multilaterales esto comentó
nuestro invitado sobre la emisión de
este bono en bitcoin
si el salvador hubiera salido a emitir
bonos en los mercados internacionales
era por el 30 de abril del 2021 la tasa
de interés que hubiera encontrado
hubiera sido una tasa de interés de
alrededor de 7% 8% si el salvador sale
en estos momentos a colocar bonos en los
mercados tradicionales la tasa de
interés que tendría que pagar sería de
20 21% entonces frente a este contexto
en el cual el gobierno necesita dinero
pero por sus propias decisiones no ha
logrado encontrarlo es que surge la idea
de colocar estos bonos volcán o bonos
con respaldo en disco pero qué es lo que
ha pasado que la realidad se ha ido
imponiendo y ahora el gobierno ha
aceptado que la emisión va a quedar en
pausa y que si se realiza quién va a
aparecer como la entidad oferente va a
ser una empresa
privada con capital
de recursos públicos encuestas locales
afirman que en noviembre pasado el 22
por ciento de comercios recibieron pagos
en bitcoin pero en febrero la cifra cayó
al 14% mientras que un 92% de
encuestados dijeron que el impacto del
bitcoin ha sido indiferente en sus
negocios en cuanto a las remesas menos
del 2% se hacen con billeteras digitales
pero el gobierno afirma que ya hay
efectos positivos por ejemplo en el
turismo entre noviembre y diciembre un
aumento del 30 por ciento de visitantes
correlacionados con el interés del mundo
de la script o divisa pero como influye
por ejemplo la guerra en ucrania en la
adopción del bitcoin en el salvador-
esto nos dijo nuestro invitado también
lo que está pasando con el conflicto y
de la invasión de rusia ucrania también
permite poner otro foco al tema del
bitcoin porque se ha observado cómo se
está utilizando
justamente para intentar superar
sanciones económicas entonces ésta puede
ser una medida que régimen autoritarios
en otros países puedan seguir diferente
a este contexto entonces creo que lo
vamos a lo que vamos a observar
precisamente son más
jorge gracias por esta información y
ustedes sigan con nosotros
[Música]